[Musik]
der schnee ist endlich aus den wählern
der syrischen tiger gewesen
reno sommerhalder unternimmt die ersten
wanderungen mit den vier bären weißen
die jungen asiatischen schwarzbären erst
wenige wochen alt haben sich
mittlerweile an den menschen gewöhnt
sie haben ihre mutter verloren und so
hat es sich somerhalder zur aufgabe
gemacht
die bärenkinder durch ihr erstes
lebensjahr zu bringen
[Musik]
nach dem sibirischen winter ist neues
leben in die wälder zurückgekehrt
eigentlich erstaunlich wer alles die
monatelange kälte überleben konnte
[Musik]
die knochen eines wildschweins überreste
einer beute
der sibirische tiger auch amur tiger
genannt ist der herrscher in diesen
wäldern und vor ihnen müssen sich die
bärenkinder in acht nehmen
[Musik]
eine kleine siedlung in einer lichtung
indoor mintal weit entfernt von der
nächsten menschlichen behausung mitten
in einer endlosen wildnis gelegen
eigentlich ist das her in jagd camp doch
nun die in die hütten als basislager ein
ambitiöses bären projekt menschen als
ersatzmütter verweist die jungbären
sergej coaching ein junger russischer
biologe hat das projekt initiiert
reno sommerhalder der schweizerisch
kanadische bären forscher unterstützt
ihn dabei regelmäßig kontrollieren die
beiden die bilder von wild der kameras
zehn solcher kameras sind in einem
weiten umkreis ums lager montieren
[Musik]
stets trägt reno sommerhalder ein
pfefferspray an seinen gurt es ist sein
einziger schutz gegen mögliche doch sehr
seltene attacken von beeren und tiger
zusammen mit sergej gold schien ist er
unterwegs um die hege der jungbären dass
sich etwa einen kilometer außerhalb des
lagers befindet niemand außer den beiden
darf sich dem gehege nähern
der menschliche kontakt zu den jungen
bären soll auf ein absolutes minimum
reduziert werden
eine gewöhnung der tiere an menschen zu
vermeiden
die langen stelligen pflanzen gehören
zum speiseplan der bären
je näher die beiden männer dem gehege
kommen desto mehr dämpfen sie ihre
stimmung
das gehege ist durch ein elektrozaun
gesichert der große raubtiere erwachsene
bern und tiger ferner hätten soll
sommerhalter und coaching vermeiden es
gänzlich zu den bären zu sprechen
die für drohungen erfolgt wortlos die
menschliche stimme soll den tieren fremd
bleiben
[Musik]
die beiden männer wechseln sich mit den
wanderungen ab es sind schweigsame tage
lange märsche geben nur von den
geräuschen des waldes
[Musik]
gelegentlich macht sich reno
sommerhalder mit einem schmerzenden
zungen geräusch oder mit wo flotten die
nachbarn nichts das an menschliche
stimme erinnern soll
asiatische schwarzbären sind kleiner als
braunbären
das kommt ihm zugute beim klettern er
ist erstaunlich welche kletter
fertigkeiten bereits diese jungen
schwarzbären zeigen fasst affen gleich
turm die jungbären selbst zuoberst in
den baumkronen herum alles selbst
gelernt ohne mutter doch manchmal
erweist sich die schwerkraft als stärker
[Musik]
auf der zufahrtsstraße nur wenige
hundert meter vom lager entfernt
entdeckt reno sommerhalder eine
aufsehenerregende ferte es ist eine
tiger spur
liga bewegen sich also in unmittelbarer
nähe zum lager zu den jungbären ein
kothaufen verrät mehr der raubkatze zum
opfer gefallen ist
aus wildschweine hatten dicke
das ist nun seit 22
[Musik]
außerdem vier kleinen asiatischen
schwarzbären leben auch drei junge
braunbären im wege diese werden heute
betäubt um sie markieren zu können
eine arbeit die den männern zuwider ist
doch sie ist unumgänglich die drei
braunbären sind seit einem jahr in der
obhut der bären forscher haben hier in
demmin bereits über wind hat hmm steht
ihre auswilderung bevor das betreiben
ist nicht ungefährlich
eine zu hohe dosis könnte die tiere
töten
die ungeliebte aktion geht schließlich
ohne probleme vonstatten bedeutung
funktioniert mache zur besserung gehen
woche zur pubertät oft verlangt wird
mehr oder weniger dass man die jungbären
irgendwie noch verfolgt vor allem nach
der auswahl der in den nächsten zwei
jahren werden wir die 300 kilometer
nördlich vor der geburt für home wäre
vielleicht halten die gut sichtbaren
ohrmarken jäger davon ab auf die tiere
zu schießen
so hoffen zumindest die datenschützer
die bayern sind jetzt mit mobiler
übersee haut und sie sind sehr gesund
sind sehr schön manche gegenüber
ausdauer wichtig ist will die bioenergie
ob die population ausgewildert werden
nach einer mehrstündigen reise ist die
kiste mit den drei bären auf einer weit
abgelegenen lichtung angelangt die tiere
sind noch etwas benommen und unsicher ob
sie den schritt in die freiheit wagen
sollen
[Musik]
es dauert mehrere minuten bis sie das
schützende gehäuse verlassen
[Musik]
mit schrägen auf die kiste um
steinwürfen werden die tiere verjagt
verbrennt es ist die letzte möglichkeit
ihn ein überlebens notwendiges
misstrauen gegen menschen einzuimpfen
es ist nicht einfach die bälle müsse
sogar ortslagen mit dasselbe gemacht und
frauen dann wenn man gestoppt wie
einfach zu sagen die wir mit einer die
zange
[Musik]
die mütter dieser schwarzbären jungen
sind im februar von jägern getötet
worden
nun versuchen deren forscher den weisen
ersatzweise zu geben was überhaupt
möglich ist
schutz vor hungrigen grossraubtieren vor
allem und sie führen die jungtiere am
plätze wo sie futter suchen und ihren
instinkten folgen können schnell zeigen
die tiere interesse für hohle bäume
erhöhen
zum überwintern
[Musik]
eine solche höhle bereits in früheren
wintern erprobt ist eben von einem
jungen jahren entdeckt worden
vielleicht wird er ja hier ende oktober
einziehen
[Musik]
ist das bloß spiel
da schon ein wenig ernst dass er proben
von dominanz wer ist der stärkere
wer überlebt
[Musik]
dieses spiel endet für die kröte
mit dem bestmöglichen ende mit einem
sprung davon ein paar tage verschwindet
reno sommerhalder allein in der wildnis
regelmäßig müssen die wildtier kameras
kontrolliert werden
mittlerweile ist es in der sibirischen
taiga subtropisch heiß und feucht
geworden mückenschwärme begleiten
sommerhalter auf schritt und tritt
stechmücken schwärmen
und da sind auch zecken sommerhalter hat
an einem abend schon 77 zecken aus den
kleidern und von da auch geprägt ein
liebliches land ist das nicht
überdies hat sich sommerhalter im
unwegsamen gelände verlaufen
schließlich findet er die wildtier
kamera doch noch
seit der letzten kontrolle sind immerhin
und tage verstrichen doch das resultat
ist ernüchternd nur nachtaufnahmen eines
rehs finden sich auf der speicherkarte
und fordert die kbv und der spur und und
wiesenhof reno sommerhalder entschließt
sich die kamera an einer waldstraße zu
montieren
warum man eine straße wodurch am ehesten
störungen durch den menschen drohen die
holz für alle straße und ich sehe wenig
befahren zum teil tagelang chaos auto
und die sind eigentlich wie mancher
straße aus effizienz köln führen bei
oder für eine theke risches viel
effizienter sich auf der straße ruft
houten austria soll sich der bus kam die
spuren auf der straße sind jedenfalls
vielversprechend und asiatischer
schwarzbär und tauschte ticker und das
sieht man schön die kantone dazwischen
sind noch relativ frisch
die spur sonntag 28
tatsächlich erwartungen erfüllen sich
bald
ein prächtiger tiger läuft vor die
kamera
[Musik]
ein luchs auf seiner nächtlichen pirsch
seine mögliche beute volk tagsüber am
meisten freut sich renault sommerhalter
über diese aufnahme zwei braunbären die
sergej chin letztes jahr in domin
ausgewählt hat das zeigt die jungs ja
noch der uwg sehr guten zustand sie
empfindet überwintert in der zauber
karbener winter höhle janson und jetzt
im juni also sie auch sportlich super
einem sehr guten zustand und es ist
schon eine erste idee ist dass die
us-regierung die methoden oder serie und
die verwandelt folglich sind
[Musik]
schöner moment ist extrem jetzt der mann
gott und das leben irgendwie viel
intensiver macht und das ist
faszinierender hauptsache ich habe eine
windmesse ruft heute dass er im moment
nicht sinnvoll was sie da sind da um
überhaupt das mexiko und und das ist für
zb sammlung sehen dass ich dich nicht so
schön ein jung wer hat ein vogelnest
entdeckt dass es sich zuoberst in einer
baumkrone befindet ist kein hindernis
[Musik]
doch herr hauptvogel wehrt sich vehement
und erfolgreich gegen den eindringling
reno sommerhalder führt über all diese
beobachtungen täglich buch seit drei
monaten ist er nun weg von seiner
familie die zurückgeblieben ist in
kanada wo sommerhalter eisbären forscher
und vortragsreisender sein auskommen
findet eine lange zeit der trennung
gewiss doch das leben hier unter bären
und tigern das leben weit ab der
zivilisation
davon könnte reno sommerhalder niemals
lassen
natürlich hat das labor sind die vorzüge
sondern sich coco schlag das hat extrem
vielen insekten lästig sind war ein
glücklichen tag verteilt was außerdem
schwierig ist ich vor der familie wachse
man einige original plant konsum oder
verbringen mit der familie
schlussendlich muss ich sagen bin ich
froh dass ich da ist wie immer mit ihrer
müssten umgang mit einem insekt der
wüste momentan möglich nötig wäre mit
einem hoffentlich später im herbst als
buch oder zu den sec die situation viel
viel besser wird sie dadurch enorm
familien oder unterzahl sowie die ganze
zeit ein guter gesprächspartner die
lawine zeit für mich
etwas außerhalb des lagers liegt ein
verlassenes holzfäller camp
zuletzt wurde es von einem imker genutzt
justin bieber vom bruder letzten jahre
und darüber werden elektroden haben wir
eigentlich auf mit solarzellen dann in
kärnten will happen zu essen haben ihnen
gott in dezentem zuletzt wenn das in dem
zb einer gestorben
eine woche nach honig
es ist natürlich schön wenn mir
irgendwie etwas komische meter monat
will auch in russland ist so
unterschiedlich aus jede wildnis sprich
bedeuten mit dabei damit will der partie
das kommando haben und die wir die ruhe
250 kilometer sind es nachher barofsky
der nex größeren stadt alles sind
verdammt lange 250 kilometer sieben
stunden dauert die fahrt besucher die
pisten was bachläufe und entlang
löchriger naturstrassen
die straße ins herz der wildnis reno
sommerhalder hegt zwiespältige gefühle
gegenüber dieser errungenschaft der
zivilisation auf und von der man weiß
einfach nicht wo
und natürlich bietet so ist einfacher
zugang zum basislager der posaunist
straßen unterwegs waren
aber politik zurückkommen verlegt werden
wo viele geschafft den kopf wieder bären
oder die ganze straße sollte möglichst
eine schlange liegt mitten auf der
straße
ratten schlangen sind ungiftig noch ihre
bisse kann schmerzhaft sein
vom fahrer ist größter aufmerksamkeit
verlangt denn im straßenbelag lauern
versteckte löcher in dem wagen bös
mitspielen können
der schaden ist glücklicherweise nicht
allzu schlimm
lediglich die ladeklappe wurde
weggerissen sommerhalter wird auf der
fahrt von einem russischen mitarbeiter
begleitet denn als ausländer dürfte er
sich in diesem wagen gar nicht ans
steuer setzen
nach mehreren stunden fahrt in der nähe
eines dorfes gelangen die reisenden
erstmals in die reichweite eines
mobilfunk signals
sablowski regionale hauptstadt eine
halbe million menschen leben hier im
äußersten osten russlands an der grenze
zu china
moskau liegt sieben tage eisenbahn tragt
entfernt die einwohnerzahl schrumpft
seit jahren einen boom stadt ist das
nicht
die entlehnen noch immer an der wand
die stadt liegt am mächtigen arme fluss
der den tigern den namen gab
der sommer haider tritt heute in einem
jugendclub auf der bären forscher ist
auch missionar und seine mission heißt
verständnis wecken für die bären nach
einer ersten begegnung mit beeren vor
über 25 jahren wuchs in ihm dem
einstigen koch die leidenschaft für die
großen pelztiere seither lebt
somerhalder unter bären und ist zu ihren
unermüdlichen botschafter geboren
wir müssen einen weg finden um mit
diesen tieren auf diesem planeten
friedlich erleben zu können 99% der
konflikte zwischen menschen per hand es
sich um menschliches fehlverhalten der
bär handeln natürlich hat nichts
falsches erfolgt bloß seine nase diese
bergen wurden weisen wiegen der wilderei
reno sommerhalder spricht von dem
projekt das ihn hierher geführt hat es
begann im vergangenen märz serie
coaching hat die vier schwarz bärenbabys
eingesammelt deren schicksal erlitten
hatten wir schon zahlreiche frisch
geborene bayern in sibirien zuvor im
februar suchen jeweils jäger mit ihren
hunden die winter höhlen der schwarzbär
nein die mütter werden erschossen
zurück bleiben die verwaisten jungen
diese wir am wenigstens die chance
erhalten auf ein weiterleben in einem
hühnerstall etwas außerhalb von caparros
werden die tiere aufgepäppelt bevor sie
später den weiten weg ins camp von
domain machen werden
und renault sommer hat er erzählt von
einem früheren auswilderungsprojekt in
russland 2004 war es als er auf der
russischen halbinsel kamtschatka
zusammen mit dem kanadischen bären
forscher charlie russell fünf braunbären
weisen im ersten lebensjahr begleitete
die umstände damals waren jedoch völlig
anders
das kamtschatka projekt fand in einem
menschenleeren gebiet statt fern von
straßen siedlungen und jägern die zwei
männer waren engem kontakt mit den
tieren und wollten dadurch auch beweisen
dass ein friedliches zusammenleben mit
bären möglich ist
[Musik]
auf sommer das vortrag folgt eine
angeregte diskussion viele ihr kennen
jemanden der auf die jagd geht ja auch
bären schießt
einige haben angst vor bären im zentrum
steht die frage ob das überhaupt geht
ein problemloses nebeneinander von bär
und mensch wir haben luchse in der
schweiz
wir hatten in den letzten jahren 67
braunbären wenn wir in der schweiz bären
wölfe luchse haben können mit all diesen
menschen dort dann sollte es auch hier
in diesen weiten wäldern möglich sein
mit dem bären zu leben
[Musik]
sommer im waldcamp von domi
das leben ist einfach hier die küche
legt im freien strom gibt es nur einige
stunden am abend sofern es noch benzin
hat für den generator
die männer bleiben unter sich dem
mobilfunk und internet reichen nicht bis
in die abgelegene waldlichtung
[Musik]
die bärenjungen haben in den letzten
monaten ihren instinkt geschärft für die
gefahren der wildnis
ein ausgewachsener schwarzbär erschreckt
die 4
wäre da nicht der mensch könnte der
große den kleinen gefährlich werden
[Musik]
schwarzbären sind allesfresser ihre
hauptsächliche nahrung sind pflanzen
auch insekten gehören zum speiseplan und
ein besonderer leckerbissen sind ameisen
die fed druckt proteinhaltige eier und
larven sind so heiß begehrt dass deren
beschaffung zur raserei gerät eine
erfreuliche begegnung im wald zuoberst
in einer baumkrone trainer sommerhalter
schicksal entdeckt die schwarz berlin
mit der gelben ruhe marke wurde vier
jahre zuvor ausgebildet und sie hat
überlebt ein ermutigende feststellung
für das projekt
in der sommerlichen tiger hat sich eine
reiche tierwelt entwickelt und was sich
nicht auf diesen wanderung zeigt gerät
in den fokus der wildtier kameras
[Musik]
ein armer tiger die größte raubkatze der
welt noch schätzungsweise 300 tiere
leben in den weiten sibiriens ein
glücksfall deshalb diese bilder
[Musik]
es ist herbst geworden
innert weniger tage hat der wind die
blätter von den bäumen gefegt am morgen
ist es bereits einigkeit
[Musik]
in den letzten wochen haben die wildtier
kameras spektakuläre tiger wähler
geliefert das ist oftmals sind hier die
dominante man nie wo man dadurch einen
kühnen offen heraus auf englisch um zwei
am nachmittag um zahn ja morgen sich
aufhalten dürfte eine weigerung die
möglichkeit so eine zu einem zu begegnen
doktor unterwegs vor seinem abgang
markiert der tiger den kratzbaum mit
duftstoffen stahlkocher bis vom
fantastischen ein ganz toller versuchen
wozu - und ich kann eigentlich nicht weg
für einen boden also ich wenig - laut
und dann ist der sonnenschutz liga
süßlicher geruch attraktive muss ich
sagen
insgesamt konnten reno sommerhalder und
sergej coaching im vergleichsweise
kleinen studie gebiet von turin acht
oder neun verschiedene tiger
identifizieren das ist eine höhere
dichte
ich hätte niemals ohne brisant von einem
vertrag von einem grossraubtiere
erwartet
und ich muss sagen so jetzt so nicht
lang um ihren hut über dem ticket 1000
jährigen studie gebiert mit der
chronologie und hirschen um die
hauptsache verbietet es hat aber viele
andere regionen im fern- und rohstoffe
russland und provinz von pretoria wo die
tiere hauptsache viel drei enorm stark
zugenommen hat
regus familie seine frau andrea und
töchterchen lara sind aus kanada
hergereist und in die blockhütte hin
domin eingezogen
weißt du von welchem tier das ist hg von
einem schweinen ein zahn von einem
wildschwein wakayama die spitze ist
damit wird das wildschwein den boden auf
und iphone zu finden mit der familie im
tiger land und stets dabei die
zweijährige arag dass keine ängste bei
der mutter die familie macht sich auf
durch die wildnis zu jener der kamera
von dir die eindrücklichen tiger bilder
stammen irgendwo da draußen ist ein
amurtiger unterwegs oder auch tiere
für die menschen bleibt die raubkatze
unsichtbar verborgen im herbstwald
anders als in indien wo in dicht
besiedelten lebensräumen jährlich
dutzende von menschen von tieren getötet
werden
wir hören im weiten sibiriens die
zweibeiner üblicherweise nicht zur
jagdbeute der raubkatze
in somalia ist nun gespannt ob sich
immer noch ein tiger hier aufhält oder
ob die gelegentliche präsenz der
menschen dem scheuen jäger gestört und
womöglich vertrieben hat
[Musik]
domin ist eigentlich ein jagd camp hier
wechseln sich aus bewohner die bären
schützer mit den jägern ab die in der
rücken siedlung ihre spuren hinterlassen
haben ein dilemma
doch die welt besonders hier in russland
ist eben nicht nach den vorstellungen
der bären schützer gemacht
ganz russland beklagt außerdem zufolge
ist enorm schwierigen berufsbilder innen
und die portion es ist praktisch
unmöglich und dumm machen mit ostrom
herr may bowles truman der serie der
branche muss kalt dass mit kontakten zu
den piraten immer warum nicht auch mal
einen körperkontakt und versuche so
syrien möglich dass wenn sie uns gewählt
werden julie payette mensch gegenüber
kostet einfach entsorgt werden
und es ist beste und machen reicht dass
damit die hier ausgewählten bären
übernehmen können
die hand vom letzten jahr mehrere videos
und deren dass sie jetzt schon eine
halbjahr london der wildnis überlebt mit
yego mittig mit anderen bei herren und
damen unter sich offensichtlich dass die
methode funktioniert ziemlich gut
funktioniert
im internet wird mit solchen bildern für
die bärenjagd in der region von cabal
offs geworden
7300 euro kostete jagd trip inklusive
ein bär oft wenn schwarzbären ihren
höhlen erschossen werden zerstören die
jäger die höhlen um einen bären
heranzukommen verschoss wenn
einheimische auf die jagd gehen einen
erschießen einen hirsch oder eine
wildsau oder auch einen bären um fleisch
zu gewinnen zum eigenen überleben nicht
um damit handel zu betreiben also eine
jagd für den eigenen bedarf für die
familie
das ist für mich eine akzeptable jagd
was mir weit weg sind
erschießt dabei ist der beste jahre und
groß und stark und mächtig ist dass man
einen der hochkulturen tanken als
statussymbol das ich mir natürlich
vehement bekannt
[Musik]
der herbst macht den wald zum
schlaraffenland passt ohne lästige
insekten allerlei bären versüßen den
vier jungen bären und das leben und das
ist auch notwendig denn ball kommt der
winter dann muss der pelz mit fett
gefüllt sein um den winterschlaf zu
überstehen
[Musik]
eine jüngste aufnahme einer wildtier
kamera ist tatsächlich aufsehenerregend
eine tigermutter mit vier jungen der
begeisterung von reno sommerhalder folgt
allerdings ernüchterung das ganze für
mich schon forscht noch wenig sensation
in ihrer kooperation so hoch fällt die
schwedter sibirisch theke dass man es
wie befindet wo extrem schwierig
überhaupt dann trotzdem ohne gott mit
vier jungtiere und natürlich frau
aufnahm können ob schlager und ortslage
aber sich mit landgang dieses gefühl für
frustration und frau holle mit dem
serien diskutiert und das geht nicht
motor aus kontaktieren und sie fördern
das jetzt kritikerin mit ihnen sehr
wertvoller vier jungtiere geschützt
werden geschützt gegen ihre vorbilder
die vom aussterben bedrohten amur tiger
sind streng geschützt in russland
doch die menschen den vergessenen osten
des landes sind und die nachfrage aus
dem nahen china nach tigerknochen und
organen des groß diesen wird in der
traditionellen medizin
eine wunder kraft zugeschrieben die
meister lüthi wurde dorf ohne die jagd
die lampe vom fisch und vom jacke vom
sammler von pinien eines symbols vorbild
und so weiter und wenn es natürlich und
der eintritt und die größe und dicke
vorne
das können für mehrere jahre sind und
sich coachen und ringel sommerhalter
sind besorgt die futterlage im wald
sieht dieses jahr schlecht aus es gibt
kaum eicheln und pinien müsse für die
bären könnte das existenziell werden
und auch für die wildschweine die
wichtigsten beutetiere der tiger die
beiden entschließen sich zu einer
nothilfe an mehreren stellen im wald
richten sie futterplätze 1
die fütterung von wildtieren ist verpönt
durch dieser wald ist in früheren jahren
durch holzfäller so stark geplündert
worden dass sich die bären schützer zu
diesem notbehelf legitimiert sehen
wildschwein kopf ist der rest einer jagd
beute die der lager koch erlegt hat der
schädel stinkt übel
und das soll er auch um den bären nasen
den weg zu weisen
[Musik]
und da es im handel da hat dann meine
pfoten abdruck von der große foto foto
von fast zwölf zentimeter durchmesser so
dass wiese tier und erich stoffe wie
hoch und runter kamera schmückt gott
vita und 20 minuten später kam ihr der
beruf ist es zu verantworten sich mit
einem kind sohn habe ein tiger
aufzuhalten
für mich vollkommen alles honig kann vor
literatur her dass der mutige sehr
selten waren überhaupt manchen angriff
der post nur das britische marine
durch die region das geht an die region
auf der welt das in der beziehung
zwischen mensch und dicker aber da ist
es so im studio gibt es kein einziger
mensch als fahrer wurde wäre der
verborgenheit politiker also ich habe
eine große sicherheit die mir und
überzeugt als mir sehr sicher sind dass
100 prozent sicherheit aber die harmlose
wald vor fallender baum oder verstellen
oder der tiger kam der familie noch viel
näher
es war vor einigen tagen unweit vom
lager die familie bewegte sich auf einer
waldstraße
wenn sich mein wald doch nur ein paar
schritte entfernt hörten die 3
das grunzen von wildschwein mit dem wild
st schie nach und das brühler form einer
theke als brüder form einer theke ovo
ist alles weg fahren ist dass ich weiß
nicht wie das beschriebene also ich will
eine ganze fraktion der körper toure
gottes ist den ganzen körper ist im
februar
es ist ein wahnsinnig in person scrooge
sie wohne ich niemals hawaii flüchtete
vor
überhaupt muss ich sagen ich habe ein
extremer druck spürt es bliebe und jede
sekunde jedes gewünschte größe vorkommen
könne
weil ich halt mich mit einem tiger
walter und ich habe immer kontakt und
das ist nächste wohl nicht bis zu dem
zeitpunkt an tiger nach oben und ich
hatte auswähle gemüse jedem möglichen
ort um zu sagen das gehört ja ziemlich
für mich ist wahnsinnig überraschung sie
andrä am zicksee jean reno die casino
wir sind ja oft bitte bei xii
ich kann ohne spur angst der andré achse
und sozial aber ich fühle mich am anfang
hat man sie machen also wirklich
situation vorsichtig loris ungeschickter
gefordert
[Musik]
es ist ende herbst die jungbären sind
kaum mehr zu wanderungen zu bewegen
die gut genährten page knäuel sind müde
geworden
allmählich bereit für den winterschlaf
zudem findet sich kaum mehr nahrung
[Musik]
mit dem ersten schnee und der
einbrechenden kälte erhält die bahn ja
die russische sauna eine besondere
anziehungskraft
[Musik]
die vier bären jungen sind nun auch mit
ohrmarken versehen bereits schon für die
auswilderung im nächsten frühling rider
jungen zeigen kein interesse daran in
einer baumhöhle zu überwintern
sie haben sich für das vertraute gehege
entschieden dass mit heu und aston zu
einer künstlichen höhle ausgestaltet
worden ist eine junge bärin hingegen die
männer nennen sie miss piggy hat für
ihren winterschlaf diese hohle linde
ausgewählt
am 17 november ziehen sich die vier
tiere zur winterruhe zurück
[Musik]
es sind die letzten tage im camp mit der
kälte kommt auch eine große stille in
die syrische tiger
[Musik]
es ist april geworden
fünf monate der winterschlaf gedauert
bis die kameras zeigen wie die
einjährigen schwarzbären mit ersten
schritten den neuen frühling begrüßen
doch das mädchen aus der baumhöhle ist
nirgends zu sehen dafür zerquetschen
beim kontrollbesuch tiger spuren
entdeckt eine raubkatze herzig miss
piggy offenbar irgendwann in den letzten
monaten gewohnt und jetzt im frühling
ist der tiger zur baumhöhle
zurückgekehrt doch da ist nun nichts
mehr zu holen
immerhin drei von vier bären weisen
haben überlebt ihr erstes lebensjahr im
tiger land von turin